one of my favorite things about this
movie with you is that you get to do
more stunts so what is something that
might make someone out there go there is
no way she's doing that on her own but
it's actually a stunt that you yourself
are pulling it off um
i actually did a lot of the the fighting
in in the kitchen scene and i really
wanted to like i
like i really wanted to prove to justin
that i that i could do it and and i
trained really hard in order to do it so
so yeah that was that was mostly me i'm
not going to say all me but mostly me
can you tell me a little bit about the
relationship between you the actor and
either your stun double or coordinator
what do you like to get from the stunt
team in order to make you feel super
comfortable and confident when you hit
the set to pull that off um to me it's
like choreography and a dance and with
me it's got to be muscle memory like you
can
give me
direction as much as you want but unless
i have it in my body i won't be able to
do it so
god bless the scent team because i was
meeting them like every day for an hour
and practicing i was like let's go
through it again let's go through it
again let's go through it again and they
were probably so
sick of me by the end but it like that's
what it takes for me to perfect it
so i just need repetition repetition
repetition and um that's really what
makes me feel safe i need to get there
on the day being 100 prepared i can't
you cannot wing it because once they get
the cameras in and you're in the set and
it feels a little bit different
you still have to have it in your body
so that's that's what makes me feel
comfortable so patience is what i need
from them just because now i'm curious
can you compare and contrast that
approach to your approach doing dialogue
heavy scenes do you also like to you
know same thing study and know your
stuff yeah i i have to it's it's similar
to i mean it's the same thing like when
i was in college there were crammers
which i was always like
like how are you able to do that
i'm not like i would have to take like
two hours a night and like
methodically
prepare i was not i was never a crammer
and like
can you imagine cramming an action scene
and being like getting there and being
like what am i what am i doing like like
that to me is like my nightmare so um
so yeah i can compare it to that same
thing with with dialogue you have to
like slowly get it
get it in there and hopefully you have
like a supportive partner like i do who
like constantly runs lines with me
because otherwise you're lost speaking
of supportive partners on set i love
talking about the value of a good scene
partner so whether it's an f9 or any of
the fast movies can you think of an
example of a scene where you were having
a tough time nailing it but your partner
in that scene if not the director pulled
something out of you that you couldn't
access yourself
yeah
um
[Music]
well the scene with paul in five where
i'm petrified of like jumping off the
roof i remember he made me feel really
comfortable and he made me feel like i
could do it um also justin and i have a
shorthand because we've worked together
on annapolis and then on four five
six
and now nine
um
so he knows how to trigger certain
things in me he knows like how to push
my buttons um
so
so yeah
i i trust him completely i fear i'm
getting into too many specifics when you
filmed this forever ago but is there an
example of how justin pushed your
buttons on f9 that kind of like lit a
fire in you
well i think often times with me it's
like
bring up my kid or bring up like how it
relates to that or or bring up um
like sometimes
justin's so funny sometimes he'll just
be like clutch and i'm just like
like it'll be like one word and i'm just
like
yes
um or sometimes it really helps me i'm
very practical it helps me to go behind
the camera and like look at this like
watch myself i'm not one of those actors
that's going to get neurotic and like
i am a neurotic actor but i'm not gonna
like it helps me to watch the
performance and go oh i see i see what's
missing i see what's not connecting
there so um it's really nice when you
work with directors who allow you to do
that this is an f9 specific but someone
recently told me in an interview that
they learned early on that it wasn't
appropriate to ask to look at dailies or
go behind the monitor have you ever been
in that situation where a director is
like i don't want you to see this but
you need to for yourself yeah i have
been in that situation but i also grew
up like on the faculty i remember they
would show dailies during lunch so you
were able to like
watch the dailies or you could like ask
karen makeup like what do they look like
how's it looking like you know or can i
see or oftentimes hair and makeup gets
the dailies and you can like sneak them
like you can you're like show me that
and or you have to know the right person
in the in the crew um
but yeah it's kind of a drag you know
it's a drag when they lie to you and
they're like i'm sorry we don't have
playback and you're just like um that's
a lie
uh
no so yeah it's it's very helpful to me
because i can tweak things and be
objective yeah i feel like i'm very uh
detail-oriented and i like to study so i
can understand that that way of
approaching it totally
so looking ahead a little with f9
jacob is a big motivating factor for mia
to return to the action and the mission
is it safe to assume that family
necessitates her return to that type of
material in the movie going forward i
hope so i think um
you know i would love to explore me and
jacob's relationship further i feel like
i feel like we touched upon the fact
that i was in communication with him
without dom knowing and that's like a
big
betrayal and we never really addressed
it i also
would love to explore like what is my
relationship to jacob
um and i also think you know i have
these like teenage kids that are that
i've that i've
sort of
for lack of a better word quarantined
and are they breaking out or they like
what are they doing because they've got
the toretto blood in them too and so
what does that look like for them
um and how does mia manage that i'd love
to see that dynamic come out as well
bringing up her being in contact with
jacob because i know you like to do your
homework did you ever come up with you
know either like a backstory or a
run-through of how those conversations
went what they talked about and things
like that
i no i think it looked more like
it
i think it looked more like mia
grappling for information or trying
hunting him down trying to find him and
him being really really elusive
and shut down
um i think that's what that looked like
so then what about doing the scene in f9
when you finally see him face to face
because it's like it's on screen for a
split second it doesn't seem a very
telling moment it is and those are the
most like justin loves giving me those
i had one i remember there was like this
massive
scene between um
dwayne johnson and and vin
and i was screaming tom and i'm the one
to like get him to stop just through a
look and i was like justin that's too
much pressure and that's kind of how i
felt like on this
where
with jacob like for a split second like
there's an acknowledgement there and
then he goes away
but i was actually i loved the way it
turned out and
on that i didn't check the monitor and i
just completely trusted justin but i was
you know i think it did speak volumes
and i was really happy
um
but yeah there's so much pressure when
those looks come up because it's like
there's so much to pack into those two
hours of a movie it's powerful it works
thank you
thank you very much huge congratulations
again